[Musique]
ravi de vous retrouver pour cette
nouvelle édition de parlement hebdo
chaque semaine un parlementaire nous
donne son regard sur les temps forts de
l'actualité à l'assemblée et au sénat et
cette semaine nous accueillons le
sénateur guillaume montaron jours jours
alors on va dérouler l'actualité avec
vous mais d'abord votre portrait en
quelques traits de plume avec style
jourdain newmont tard bonjour vous êtes
né dans la belle ville de tours vous
êtes architecte de formation vous avez
construit votre parcours politique en
commençant par le conseil municipal du
persil petit village du vercors de 178
habitants exactement les fonds local
c'est un peu votre truc hein mr du
persil en 2008 candidats au
départemental en 2015 élu sénateur de
l'isère en 2017
2010cette vous siégez alors au sein du
groupe communiste mais en 2020 élections
sénatoriales vous êtes réélu et vous
décidé de rejoindre le tout nouveau
groupe écologiste dans la foulée vous en
êtes élu président bonne nouvelle
guillaume gontard fin du port du masque
en extérieur fin du couvre-feu à partir
de ce week-end vous applaudissez le
gouvernement moi je sais pas si j'ai
applaudi le gouvernement mais en tout
cas c'est sûr que c'est une bonne
nouvelle on a passé une période très
compliqué très difficile et pour chacun
d'entre nous et c'est vrai que
d'ailleurs moi j'ai plutôt une une
pensée pour les plus précaires ceux qui
sont plus grandes difficultés parce que
c'est vrai que cette période a été
compliquée mais l'a été encore plus
compliqué pour certains d'entre nous est
hélas elle va l'être encore plus que
cette sortie crise bien sûr qu'on va
enlever nos masques etc
mais on sait que on l'a vu sur la
question des étudiants mais on a vu
aussi sur la question des plus précaires
cette situation risque d'être encore
compliqué quelques dents emmanuel macron
a réussi son pari face à l'épidémie
vous pouvez le dire en tout cas moi et
avec avec le groupe écologie solidarité
des territoires
on a toujours été constructif et en tout
cas
trouver des solutions faire des
propositions la question de la
vaccination était est et je pense au
centre de cette bataille
je pense qu on y est on y est arrivé
puisque une grande proportion de gens se
sont se sont fait vacciner et qu'on va
en sortir
et d'ailleurs on a vu que quand on
expliquer les choses les gens se se
faisait vacciner qu'on n'a pas eu ce
blocage con qu'on prédisait alors
guillaume quintard l'actualité c'est
aussi cette plainte déposée devant la
cour de justice de la république par le
député européen pierre larrouturou et le
militant écologiste cyril dion
cette plainte vise jean castex ainsi que
quatre autres ministres dont barbara
pompili pour inaction climatique
est-ce que vous soutenez cette
initiative bien sûr je soutiens et en
même temps je dirais je regrette parce
que si on est obligé d'arriver sur ce
type d'action
judiciaire je pense que ça pose un vrai
problème quoi on devrait être et je
pense qu'on peut faire le parallèle
entre cette crise climatique cette
urgence climatique et cette lutte contre
le réchauffement climatique et l'épisode
qu'on vient de vivre et vous serez
puissant sur les sanitaires et marché
mais je regardais sur la crise année sur
cette crise sanitaire
on a tout mis en oeuvre le coup de que
coûte voilà on avait cette bataille le
président de la république a parlé de a
fait à fait adéquat des comparaisons
avec avec des langages de deux guerres
en disant il fallait il fallait qu'on y
aille
on est exactement sur la même
problématique mais sur du long terme et
je veux dire un impact qui pète en qui
saura de tourner à son ciel encore plus
fort vous mais il a surpris et si on
avait dit sur la question des vaccins de
dire oui on va attendre un petit peu on
va attendre cinq ans parce que les gens
sont pas tout à fait prêt est ce que
c'est pour régler ces problèmes la
position sur la question sur la question
climatique on est exactement dans cette
danse est même mais ça va passer par la
justice selon vous on passe par la
justice parce que quand il ya une action
quand on a des mesures qu'entend et un
autre entre notre pays dans lequel il a
signé des accords de paris ça s'est
passé ici chez nous et que on a je
dirais le culot de déposer un texte sur
le climat qui ne respectent pas ces
accords de paris ça pose quand même un
problème est qu'à un moment
effectivement cette inaction si on voit
qu'on a des responsables politiques qui
devrait avoir cet engagement et c'est
pour notre santé c'est pour notre
bien-être
je rappelle que on sort d'une crise
sanitaire c'est hélas plus de cent mille
morts la pollution actuellement chaque
année tue plus de 80000 personnes
donc on devrait avoir cette cette même
action et je pense qu'on a intérêt à
pousser
que ce soit au niveau citoyens que ce
soit au niveau juridique et puis bien
sûr nous au niveau politique c'est ce
qu'on a fait avec la vraie loi qui m'a
guillaume vantard on en parle justement
trois temps forts au parlement cette
semaine que l'on commente avec vous au
sommet
de cette semaine environ 200 articles
plus de 2000 amendement déposé le projet
de loi qui m'a été examiné par les
sénateurs depuis lundi ont fait le point
dans un instant aux tensions en séance à
l'assemblée nationale majorité et
opposition se sont divisés sur le calcul
de l'allocation adulte handicapé le
gouvernement est passé en force
explications dans un instant
pas de vacances pour députés sénateurs
avant le mois d'août le parlement
siégera en session extraordinaire au
mois de juillet avec un programme
extrêmement chargé ça fait réagir vous
verrez mais d'abord le top départ pour
la loi climat examiné au sénat
[Musique]
suppression du délit d' écocide
réaffirmation des engagements de la
france en matière de réduction des gaz à
effet de serre depuis lundi le sénat
modifie le texte climat du gouvernement
voit ça avec sagna de chiens le marathon
du projet de loi climat s'est ouvert au
sénat sur une note de consensus pour les
sénateurs le texte n'est pas à la
hauteur pour lutter contre le changement
climatique
la quasi-totalité des groupes a donc
voté pour l'introduction d'un article
dans lequel la france s'engage à réduire
ses émissions de gaz à effet de serre de
50 5% d'ici 2030
en réalité la france est déjà lié à cet
objectif européen mais la version
initiale du texte n'aurait pas permis de
l'atteindre
d'après les calculs du haut conseil pour
le climat les sénateurs ont donc voulu
le réinscrire noir sur blanc
c'est extrêmement important et je crois
que c'est la première fois que le sénat
dans sa diversité dit son accord avec
cet objectif européen et finalement le
soutien politique à la négociation
internationale quelque part madame la
ministre cet amendement c'est un peu un
cadeau le sénat vous fait une fois cet
engagement inscrit dans l'introduction
du texte le sénat a entamé l'examen du
volet consommation
le projet de loi prévoit d'indiquer dans
l'affichage environnemental des produits
si sa fabrication respecte les droits
humains mais seulement à titre
facultatif écologistes et socialistes
ont donc fait voter un amendement pour
rendre l'information obligatoire
comment pourrions nous tolérer demain
qu'un produit bénéficie d'un affichage
environnemental élogieux si dans le même
temps il a été produit dans des
conditions de travail déplorables proche
de l' esclavage moderne ou par des
enfants il nous semble indispensable de
faire cet effort dans la construction du
futur affichage
le texte prévoyait aussi de réduire la
publicité pour les produits polluants
grâce à un code de bonne conduite dans
l'audiovisuel public
la majorité sénatoriale a voulu aller
plus loin elle a introduit une
interdiction dès 2023 de ces publicité
sur france télévisions radio france et
france mais diamant
cette disposition en temps comme c'est
souvent le cas en la matière faire de
l'audiovisuel public un pionnier en
matière de transition écologique sans
pour autant affecter de façon importante
les recettes de nos services publics
car ils pourront toujours faire de la
publicité sur des produits et services
ayant un effet moindre sur
l'environnement une interdiction adopté
malgré l'opposition de la gauche qui
accuse la droite d'affaiblir
l'audiovisuel public
amputé d'une partie de ses recettes
publicitaires au profit du privé
guillaume gontard la france à 10 ans
pour atteindre 55 % de baisse des gaz à
effet de serre objectifs européens pour
2030 avec ce texte on va y arriver
on le sait déjà puisque le texte qui
était pour proposé par le gouvernement
qui est sorti de l'assemblée nationale
et à 20 30 % suivant les chiffrages 1 et
suivants les les analystes qu'on peut
avoir donc on le sait déjà le
gouvernement le sait le sait déjà sur
les mesures qu'on a pu voir et qui ont
été prises jusqu'au débat ici au sénat
oui on a fait on à améliorer des choses
et je dirais le groupe écologiste a
vraiment poussé j'ai vu mon collègue
chef de file notre chef de file ronan
ronan dantec sur cet amendement qui
inscrit justement ces 55 % et ce respect
et des règles des règles climatique
française et des accords de paris dans
le texte était quelque chose d'important
et heureusement qu'on a eu cette
initiative pour je pense à nanterre dit
qu'on a rendu service à barbara conflit
je pense parce que au moins on a quand
même c'était quand même assez fou que ça
soit pas un sommelier deux ans et ex
mais par contre quand on regarde les
mesures qui sont dans le texte on voit
bien qu'on va arriver
alors on verra à la fin sur ce qui est
le texte du sénat on arrivera alors
qu'on a et je répète sur cette urgence
on a cent quatorze mois pour atteindre
ses seins et c'est cette baisse de gaz à
effet de serre 20 % chaque point perdu
sa voix période
la ministre nous dit vous dit juger nous
sur l'ensemble notre oeuvre
vous vous vous jugiez commençons son
action vous lui mettez quelle note entre
1 et 10 pour l'instant je
je dis juste que ben que la copie est
ratée puisque on n'atteint pas ses
objectifs et donc c'est pas possible
avec ce fait la comparaison sur la crise
sanitaire c'est quand c'est comme si on
nous disait on a des vaccins on les
garde
et on les utilisera plus tard c'est pas
possible il faut qu'on agisse est ce
qu'il faut bien voir c'est que c'est
facile c'est que les propositions les
mesures qu'on doit mettre en place
on les a on a conçu on a proposé une
vraie loi climat santé ça coûte cher et
qui j'avais fait chier chiffrés et qui
est chiffré aussi en baisse d'émissions
de gaz à effet de serre en tonne carbone
et donc nous on comprend très bien qu'il
puisse y avoir un débat et de dire telle
mesure est trop complexe ne veut pas
être acceptées mais alors par quoi on la
remplace et en garde cet objectif de
baisse de 55% des gaz à effet serre
sachant qu'il faudrait même déjà allé
plus loin que l'allemagne a déjà annoncé
qu'elle irait qu'elle irait plus loin et
donc on a réellement besoin de passer à
l'acte est ce qu'il faut voir c'est que
toutes les mesures qu'on propose
ce sont des mesures les écolos châssis
la mettre bien sûr ce sont des mesures
qui sont faciles à mettre en place qui
sont vraiment au tour de la justice
sociale qui permettent le mieux vivre le
bien vivre
donc on n'y a tous intérêt donc en fait
c'est cette absence de passage à l'acte
et je dirais que la droite
présidentielle dans son style et la
droite sénatoriale dans son style n'ont
pas les mêmes séries comme gide mois
qu'on me prouve comme le prouve et qu'on
me dise comment la droite peut atteindre
pour l'instant j'ai vu aucun document
qui nous prouve que c'est possible sur
l'actuelle à chaque fois des bars nous
explique il faut attendre c'est pas
maintenant ils ça sera plus tard il ya
un moment très important qui a été
adopté par le sénat cet amendement il va
permettre au maire
s'opposer à l'installation d'éoliennes
sur leur commune bonnes nouvelles
mesures c'est une très mauvaise mesure
quand on a eu un débat on a eu un débat
hier soir sur la question de l'éolien
première chose on va avoir un débat sur
la question énergie sur les déplacements
voiture électrique hydrogène à un moment
donné il va bien falloir qu'on produise
électricité il faut aussi qu'on ait
cette sobriété bien sûr qu'on diminue
mais il va falloir aussi qu'on sorte de
la dépendance et de nos dépendances
notamment au pétrole mais aussi à
l'uranium est donc au niveau là on est
totalement dépendant la seule énergie
sur lequel on retrouve notre
souveraineté
c'est l'énergie renouvelable que ça soit
d'hydroélectricité que ça soit l'éolien
où que ce soit oui mais aujourd'hui on
dit qu'un maire et son conseil municipal
va pouvoir décider pour l'ensemble on
est à linverse de l'intérêt général
quand vous travaillez sur des éoliennes
sur des éoliennes l'a vu l'impact et
bien au delà d'une commune c'est pour
l'intérêt général et donc qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire on a la solution
il faut qu'on travaille on a une une pe
qu'une orientation de l'énergie sur
plusieurs années eh bien il faut qu'on
la cartographie qu'on réfléchisse à
l'échelle alors ça peut être à l'échelle
régionale
je pense que l'échelle des d'estrade est
inquiet qui est le document de réflexion
à l'échelle régionale peut être ça pour
réfléchir globalement sur comment
répartissez énergie que ça soit le
solaire que ça soit les l'éolien pour
justement caissettes acceptabilité là
mais pas parce par ces moyens qui sont
je dirais très quelque peu populiste 1
pour dire une éolienne c'est pas beau on
va laisser la main à tel conseil
municipal qui va avoir l'effet inverse
puisque on va créer de la concurrence
entre les qu'entre les communes que les
opérateurs vont s'en emparer et ça va
être au plus offrant et on arrivera à
une heure de quoi un autre projet de loi
revient à l'assemblée pour inscrire le
climat dans la constitution députés et
sénateurs ne sont pas d'accord sur les
termes de la modification
constitutionnelle est ce que ça veut
dire que le référendum promis par
emmanuel macron sur ce sujet va échouer
j'ai l'impression qu'il le savait déjà
quand il
il a lancé l'idée
quand on est sur un jeu de ping pong
entre encore une fois entre la droite
présidentielle et la droite sénatoriale
voilà je pense qu'on n'est pas à la
hauteur des enjeux
nous on a joué le jeu quand le texte est
passé en 10 ans on est d'accord c'est le
texte qui était proposée par le
gouvernement il est issu pour le coup
une promesse retenue et c'était le texte
de la convention citoyenne ont souhaité
aller plus loin on sait qu'on sait
réservé aux chaînes à céret jamais en
disant il faut qu'on ait de votre
confort parce que l'on souhaite
on souhaite aller donner la parole aux
citoyens qui est ce référendum
c'est quand même assez fou que la droite
sénatoriale gaulliste et refuser ce
passage ce passage au référendum et
laisser la place veut dire s'il avait
les arguments n'y avait aucun souci à
droite se nourrir de victoire à emmanuel
macron sur ce sujet du climat à quelques
mois de la prescrivent les françaises et
les français d'un débat démocratique
je trouve que c'est c'est
particulièrement regrettable et puis
pour terminer il y à une solution assez
simple si emmanuel macron veut aller au
bout
c'est de convoquer le congrès dire et de
poser ce texte devant le devant le
congrès et le tour est joué on peut le
faire
en juillet on est disponible et on
n'attend que ça guillaume compta autre
sujet à la une au parlement l'allocation
adulte handicapé à l'assemblée la séance
a été très tendue
[Musique]
est à l'origine de l'affrontement une
proposition de loi communiste qui
propose ne plus faire dépendre la hache
des revenus du conjoint la mesure est
soutenue par quasiment toutes les
oppositions toutes les oppositions mais
le gouvernement a préféré un simple
abattement fiscal explications contre en
10 séances avec elsa monde à gâvres à
une séance électrique dans l'hémicycle
les députés s'affrontent sur
l'individualisation de la hache
l'allocation aux adultes handicapés une
mesure souhaitée par tous les groupes
d'opposition ainsi que le groupe agir
alliés de la majorité soit vivre en
couple soit être indépendant
financièrement
voilà donc le choix inhumains que nous
imposons aux personnes handicapées ce
choix est dénoncé par l'ensemble des
associations comme un odieux est très
élevé prix de l'amour mais le
gouvernement soutenu par les députés
marcheurs et du modem s'oppose à cette
des ponts jug alisation une politique de
redistribution fondé même sur cette
politique de comptes de calcul ou la
solidarité familiale vient en complément
d'un solidarité nationale dans un climat
tendu assumer le vous l'avez dit c'est
un arbitrage budgétaire et j'en appelle
tout simplement à votre sens de la
compassion et avec la crainte d'un vote
serré
la secrétaire d'état annonce la réserve
des votes puis un vote bloqué les
députés s'exprime sur l'article 3
modifié par le gouverneur chers
collègues
que
je fume pour les collègues la réserve
c'est très pénible le vote bloqué c'est
un scandale pour l'assemblée tête ont
une rente ce que vous êtes en train de
faire vous c est en fait aujourd'hui de
porter une atteinte très grave pour vous
finalement la proposition de loi est
adopté
mais sans sa mesure principale clos
voilà alors la séance a effectivement
été très agité vote réservé votre blocs
et sait comment vous expliquer tout ce
tumulte dans l'hémicycle sur un sujet
aussi sensible
comment vous décryptez ça c'est cette
situation pour moi elle est allée elle
est totalement inexplicable et je
reprends les mots de certains face et
c'était total c'est totalement honteux
totalement scandaleuse qui s'est passé
et il a préalablement à tous les
problèmes bien sûr et à tous les points
de vue c'est à dire que sur le sur le
fond et sur ce texte le fait
d'individualiser une éducation
handicapés le dire l'handicap il
individuel il est il est pour soi c'est
la personne qui le porte est donc bien
évidemment ça doit être individualisée
ça doit rester à la personne mais en
plus sûre sur la forme un vote bloqué ça
veut dire quoi ça veut dire que le
gouvernement dit voilà c'est comme ça ça
sera pas autrement et on bloque le débat
parlementaire vous votez pour ou contre
ce que je sais c'est totalement c'est le
jeu non le jeu parlementaire c'est de
pouvoir amender ses pouvoirs débat s'est
constitué aussi s'est ensuite bien sûr
que c'est concessionnels mais c'est un
vrai choix est sur un sujet et sur un
sujet comme ça de quoi on parle de 808
euros 46 pour une personne seule qui
touchent donc du coup cette allocation
et on lui dit si si tu te maries si tu
te pacs si tu fais le choix de l'amour
bah tu vas devoir tu veux tu vas devoir
choisir justement entre cet amour entre
vivre avec quelqu'un et puis cette
allocation c'est totalement scandaleux
gouvernants et en même temps en dérision
et en même temps lui dis sinon tu restes
étaient parents parce que si tu restes
chez tes parents
là tu touches tu continues à toucher ton
allocations c'est totalement
inimaginable sur jeu on parle
globalement de 750 millions d'euros
alors ça peut paraître beaucoup en fait
quand on regarde globalement c'est loin
du compte mais on voit bien qu'on est
dans dans ce dogme
libéral dans ce 2 ne m'en étais dans
cette idéologie de l'argent qui est pour
moi totalement révolu langon tard on
avait sur le fond on a entendu le
gouvernement sophie cluzel défendre ses
arguments point par coin en assumant sa
position elle a dit qu'elle a défendu la
solidarité familiale ou solidarité entre
époux est ce que vous entendez cet
argument mais absolument pas yaya aucune
solidarité dans ce qui a été défendu ils
ont relevé le plafond
enfin cinq mille 5000 euros c'est pas ça
qui va changer les choses
l'individualisation ses dires de dire ce
que vous touchez c'est lié à votre
handicap
un point c'est tout je veux dire c'est
un combat au même titre qu'en 1965 et
intègre justement pour que les femmes et
leur autonomie financière c'est-à-dire
puisse signer un chèque puisse ouvrir un
compte en banque sans l'autorisation de
leur mari
c'est du même ordre ça veut dire d'avoir
sept personnes handicapées qu'elles
soient hommes ou femmes c'est cette
liberté de vivre comme elles le
souhaitent en coupe ou pas en coupe le
ton contre moi ce que je trouve c'est
totalement incompréhensible et je
rappelle qu emmanuel macron c'était sa
cause nationale le handicap
oui où on en est comme je la rate et là
une occasion totalement s'est totalement
ratée y revient c'est totalement est ce
que ce qu'il faut quand même voir si je
regardais les témoignages de ces
personnes derrière on a on a des femmes
on allait des hommes qui ont un handicap
et l'image qu'on leur envoie moi je suis
la preuve c'est que on avait déposé un
texte à l'époque que vous avez rappelé
j'ai été rattachée au groupe crc eux
c'était laurence cohen et j'étais
jusqu'au signataires de ce texte en 2018
au sénat à l'époque il avait pas été
signé ils n'avaient pas été votés il n'a
pas été voté non plus par la droite la
droite sénatoriale au sénat on a évolué
on a évolué et on voit bien que de la
france insoumise on a vu on a vu
françois ruffin jusqu aux républicains
tout le monde est d'accord les mesures
l'a bien compris les choses d'un camion
je ne comprends pas ce blocage on nous
procéderons tard on nous promettait un
texte à part entière sur le grand âge
sept années au parlement pour l'instant
rien à l'horizon vous les appelez de vos
voeux cette loi va bien vite et bien
évidemment dire quand on quand on se se
baladant dans les élections munis dé
partement talent actuellement cette
question sociale cette question du grand
âge comment justement on traite nos
anciens qu'on a pu
parler je dirais concrètement et là sur
la situation notamment des ehpad pendant
cette crise sanitaire
on a cette nécessité là on nous l'a
promis à chaque fois on nous a renvoyés
de date en date là on voit bien que bas
n'aura pas on n'aura pas de texte avant
la fin du camp tu écris quinquennat ces
partis ne rentrerez table et c'est
encore une fois je vire avec ces deux
exemples bla on voit bien que la
question sociale
la question de la vie des gens
n'intéresse pas ce gouvernement on va en
parler justement puisque le programme
parlementaire de l'été guillaume gontard
est déjà très chargé
[Musique]
pas de vacances pour députés et
sénateurs avant le mois d'août guillaume
gontard le parlement termine en principe
un ses travaux à la fin du mois de juin
mais emmanuel macron a convoqué les deux
chambres pour une session extraordinaire
au mois de juillet programme extrêmement
chargé avec une quinzaine de grands
textes à examiner et ça fait réagir
écouter chacun peut se rendre compte que
si on respecte le parlement et si nous
voulons que le parlement vote la loi
après des discussions approfondies un
travail qui nous permettent aussi
d'auditionner toutes les personnes
compétentes
ça demande un peu de temps et qu' il ne
faut pas forcer le passage à tout prix
d'ailleurs vous fais le pari que sur
cette liste de textes qui est un petit
peu un inventaire à la prévert il faudra
bien s'accommoder du fait que la
discussion ne pourra pas aller au bout
dès le mois de juillet et qu'il faudra
continuer le travail et c'est bien ainsi
dieu me gontard qui trop embrasse mal
étreint
mais j'entendais la question n'est pas
de savoir si les parlementaires ont des
vacances ou pas on est là pour ça on est
là pour étudier des textes donc c'est
pas la problématique elle n'est pas là
la preuve indique c'est comment on
étudie ces textes et dans quelles
conditions on est actuellement sur la
loi climat avec vous avez rappelé plus
de deux mille deux mille amendements
faire des amendements travail et ça
c'est un vrai travail
en commission et on a besoin de ce temps
là et on a besoin aussi le travail
parlementaire c'est le lien aussi avec
le terrain avec nos concitoyennes et
concitoyens
en même temps on a toute une série de
textes à en a le texte d'importance
quand même la loi la fameuse loi cadets
inquiet sur l'organisation à sion la
décentralisation et qui est justement
l'organisation des régions du
département des intercommunalités
toutes ces questions là des questions
démocratiques qu'on nous met en ce
moment alors qu'on est en élection
départementale et régionale donc vous
voulez vous qu'on ait ce travail avec
des équipes qui vont changer et comment
voulez vous qu'on essaie ces échanges
donc oui c'est fait à la va-vite bien
trop rapidement sans avoir ce temps des
changes ces partis musulmans regrettable
mais c'est encore une fois on le sait ce
gouvernement un vrai problème avec avec
le parlement avec la démocratie veut
passer en force
on sait qu'à les élections
présidentielles que macron veux faire
tout ce qu'il n'a pas pu faire pendant
pendant cinq ans et c'est regrettable je
pense qu'on l'a on doit voir ce temps de
travail et cet échange démocrates en
tout cas pas de réforme des retraites à
l'horizon si jamais elle devait être
inscrire à l'ordre du jour vous
descendez dans la rue contre cette
réforme c'est évident enfin je veux dire
déjà cette réforme de retraite tels que
picasso sur se méfie quand on parle de
réforme fasse dire oui aux réformes on
n'est jamais contre une réforme
la réforme qui était proposée sur la
retraite est purement scandaleuse
encore une fois on est à l' inverse de
ce qu il faudrait faire au niveau au
niveau social au niveau de la
répartition au niveau de la répartition
des richesses toujours dans cette même
direction que souhaite donner le
gouvernement
j'espère bien entendu qu on y reviendra
pas dessus avant le quinquennat et puis
que pour le coup ça sera un vrai débat à
voir est un vrai choix de société
au niveau des présidentielles et encore
une fois les écologistes on a vraiment
des choses à proposer sur cette cette
question alors vous avez quoi proposer
en quelques mois une bien sûr une
meilleure répartition est aussi un vrai
un vrai travail sur un vraie réflexion
sur le sur le temps de travail
je pense que on ne pourra pas faire
l'économie de ce jugement de cette
question du temps de travail de cette
question du partage du travail
je ne comprends pas comment on peut
encore nous dire qu'il va falloir
travailler plus travailler plus
longtemps
quand on sait que la durée de vie en
bonne santé ne fait que c'est ce que
baisser dans notre ville mois des
présidentielles en a encore le temps de
réformer de changer les choses où tout
est parti dans la campagne déjà on va en
sens bien que là il ya une accélération
et qu'on est oui je dirais déjà entré en
pré-campagne
mais c'est pour ça je pense qu un
président responsable un gouvernement
responsable aurait dû justement gérer ce
temps et qu'on arrive à une une pige à
une pause démocratique qu'on puisse
aborder les sujets tranquillement et de
manière sérieuse
ce qui n'est pas le cas et ce que je
trouve particulièrement regrettable
c'est le mot de la fin merci beaucoup
merci d'avoir répondu à nos questions
merci katia on se retrouve la semaine
prochaine pour un nouveau numéro de
parlement hebdo excellent week-end à
tous statcan
[Musique]